tout le monde arrête l'action épisode 8 ça alors
le premier film n'avait pas de numéro
Ryan a écrit une histoire qui est
inattendue mais juste certaines des choses
qui arrivent aux gens que sans oh mon
dieu même si je pense que je sais tout,
ils me jettent des choses sur l'histoire  sage, je
n'aurais jamais pu imaginer et même
si tout le monde sait que c'est le deuxième
de la trilogie, on a l'impression que son propre
truc
va
Star Wars est tellement cool parce qu'il y a toutes
ces créatures
toujours émerveillées par l'effet visuel
comme tous les personnages sont aussi si
complexes
Ryan mr.  accueille wiki sois ah
particulaire nouveau directeur cannabis
apprenant qu'il sonne
[Musique]
on a l'impression que les intrigues sont devenues plus
établies, nous apprenons vraiment à connaître
ces nouveaux personnages aussi avec les
personnages que nous connaissons et aimons
dans leur vie change
tout est en train de changer  d'une
manière positive, donc ce à quoi vous vous attendez
après que la star de sept demoiselles d'honneur se
rafraîchisse  de la bière contre
les
vêtements diaboliques dans le maintien qu'il y avait un
véritable esprit de mort aujourd'hui à
propos de la famille et c'est ce qui est si
puissant à ce sujet